[Applaudissements]
mais là
mais
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
le grand concours des chorales tous les
chroniqueurs jouer n'aura aussi tu vas
jouer alors je lui dis c'est très simple
ce sont des questions sur la télé je
vous posais des questions comme d'un
grand concours des animateurs chacun
votre tour d'accord et non mnam vous ne
tournez pas si vous tombez truc je vous
dis tout de suite je vous sors si la
dent mais je vous sors je vous sors donc
tourné pas le truc arrêté benhaim voilà
je cherche à mike patton voila voila je
vous le dis merci jambes et non celui
qui tourne je sois je me sens bien dans
cette totale un trou alors les chéris
attention je vous pose des questions
chacun votre tour il en restera car la
fin le grand gagnant gagnera un
magnifique cadeau pour mon anniversaire
puisque il gagnera également acheté pmp
jeu la console wii la console c'est une
exclusivité micromania et le fis et
après vous continuez voilà c'est une
bombe
attention marc vous joue également avec
nous est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui
après on aura bien sûr le coup de coeur
le coup de gueule sur les propos chocs
de chaque consignes d'on n'est pas
couché il a complètement pété un câble
vraiment je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
il a dérapé le petit aléatoire c'est
parti
quel sport est à l'honneur dans le jeu
de vincent lagaf strike benjamin
castaldi quel sport quoi
on
la lame et castany vous êtes éliminés
cette version c'est moral et c'était
bien sûr le triple a tranché t il à vos
changements
c'était le bowling aller aux côtés
d'emma compris la question vous êtes
éliminés ou sans laquelle émission oulaï
m'énerve la démission par quelle
émission a pour but initial cuts pérusse
et il faut qu'on pense
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ce calibre laissez moi d'abord réduit
également des limites qui est inculpé au
sénat il m'a quand même dit qu on se
touche à la fois soul dossier pour le
premier et les attentions 3g très bonne
émission comment se trouve dans fort
boyard qui est monique en jonc qui est
monique on joue à l'est qui manigancent
en novembre dernier grange ont fait
l'essai qui vous des tigres attention
maxime kenny qui va présenter prodige
sur france 2 la place de marianne james
f les murs qui vient chez gilles verdez
n'appréciez pas que c'est toi qui donne
une réponse et des spécialistes comme
c'est un joueur de tennis à chaban qui
renvoie la balle à ce qu'on fait fondée
au sabbat attention gilles verdez qui
présente balances ton post vendredi soir
c'est rien n'a rien attention vous
hormis basara castaldi christophe
beaugrand quel animateur a déjà présenté
secretstory isabelle morini-bosc ses
craintes je me souviens plus ah oui
allez c'est bon
nikos bien sûr nous faire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention daniel go c'est nikos aliagas
il a remplacé deux fois benjamin
castaldi dans sieccan story qui a été le
premier présentateur d amour sur france
2 jean luc reichmann
oui bonne réponse à mon attention non
vous avez tourné non rattachés voir vrai
ou faux florian philippot le parrain des
prochains à marrakech du rire
[Rires]
attention donc à l'émission de tf1 ils
sont reçus bellâtre alessandra sublet at
elle débuté à l'est bernard authié trois
zones attention et non il n'en est que
plus il ne reste plus ignorer ce plus
que voulait jouer droit pas sûr encore
sequana est bouclée non vraiment allez
donc vous êtes sûrs et au faso
elle signifie la lettre m du logo m6 non
attention attention au ras minik mais
c'est pas inquiète pas j'ai plein de
trucs pour toi alors attention et nora
une chuis les métropoles c'était
métropole fra bat attention away gilles
verdez désormais sa mère belge jean
michel bernier tel est le nom du premier
gagnant de la nouvelle star allait dîner
faire ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jonatan cerrada exactement attention la
question pour vous qu'est le cerveau
même s'il est bien qu'ils étaient
nombreux le premier présentateur de zone
interdite créée en 1993
zone interdite s'était présenté par
bernard de la villardière
[Musique]
ses caprices
c'est patrick de carolis il ne reste
plus que trois c'est gilles verdez
attention quel est le nom de famille de
mimie mathy dans joséphine ange gardien
ou l'eau on n'a aucune idée comment ça
[Applaudissements]
et
attention ça va se jouer entre daniel
moreau entre daniel moreau et géraldine
m'a dit ah les ventes révisées à la non
attention dans quelle émission de
christine bravo at on découvert que
nikos aliagas cvo vignerons dur a dit
oui n'aura à tokyo a gagné le mot quel
est le nom de famille de nagui sais je
sais comme on s'en fout alors là c'est
pas savait pas quand vous êtes sûr si je
vous dis f
du bilan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une console